foreign
North Carolina Welcome to the Ramsey
show Tom
hey how y'all doing thanks for taking my
call sure what's up
all right so I'm gonna get right to the
point
um
I'm in financial peace I got every
dollar
um
but my dilemma is that I share custody
of my son my schedule allows me to have
him on the days that I'm off
but if I'm going to pursue getting out
of debt as quickly as I need to it would
result in me having to give up some of
those days
and that is the part that I'm struggling
with
how old is she
he's won
how long have you all been divorced uh
over a year
I'm so confused
so he's won and you've been divorced
over a year yeah so we we it happened
all kind of at the same time yes sir all
right so about the same timeline okay
yes yes so we'll make him the same age
as the divorce okay that helps me a
little all right and so um all right now
uh um
what do you do for a living
uh I drive a truck
over the road
uh no I'm local sure you're working 40
hours
uh I well with overtime
um I'm looking at about
90 every two weeks
45 hours
yes sir okay and
um how much debt do you have
um so total debt is let's call it 27k
it's 26 729 yeah and what do you make
now
um so my take home is 60k okay so your
typical day when you're driving truck
not when you're with your son you go to
work at what time
uh about 10 A.M
okay and you drive then until about 8 00
p.m 8 8 PM yes sir yeah okay all right
that gets you here 45 hours all right
yes sir okay
what about
on the days you don't have your son
you're at 50 50 you said
yes so yes sir yeah what days of the
week
I'm sorry say that again what day of the
week is that
so we work on a two two three schedule
okay
um so it rotates every every every week
so basically in the two week period I
get him seven days out of the out of
that two-week period okay
um
and I'm just struggling with do I want
to give up one of my days and have a
babysitter or have a family member watch
him while I go and work if I was you
yes sir
I would be pretty intentional about
getting up at 5am on the days I don't
have to be until 10 and drive Uber and
Lyft in the morning
I am doing a side hustle as well okay
um
that kind of tacks into the what is that
uh so it's Amazon Flex okay all right
and you're doing that in the mornings
before you go to work yes sir so in a
strange way and Dave you've done this
longer than me on this particular
question
if this was inside your home
I would if you're if you and your wife
and your boy lived inside in the same
house I would tell you hit the gas work
seven days a week and get this 27 bucks
27 000 off your chest
yes the fact that this is broken up in
this way
with how rapid a one-year-old develops
six months of no dad
it's not that's not okay it's glaring
it's too much yeah I'm with you I'd
rather slow the roll on paying off the
debt and make sure I've got that time
with my son because that time is
precious what is the 27 000 in debt what
kind of debt
is gonna ask
um
so 20K that is car God Almighty sell
your car it's your kid I know
you don't know because you didn't you
had to ask why'd you have to ask and you
didn't even want to tell us because you
knew we were going to say what you
already knew you should do it's your kid
or trade your car for a kid
yes sir so your stupid car this week
what kind of car is it Tom
it's a Honda Civic oh my God don't trade
a Civic for a kid for sure
Tom not even a really cool car
I mean come on yeah if it was like a
Mercedes well I mean if I mean no if it
was a you know vintage Camaro I mean
give me a oh my gosh no I'm not talking
I'm kidding around Tom but yeah really
you got this figured out you just
thought through it get you a one
thousand dollar car
and take care of your one-year-old and
get your butt out of debt work and
you're working and live on beans and
rice rice and beans and do not miss a
single day that you have available for
this child he is the most important
thing in this conversation I will affirm
you as being a good dad you have a good
heart you are aimed at the right thing
you knew you needed to do that but
you're trying to make the math work and
keep the car and so we get to tell you
the classic Ramsay show line sell the
car
yes sir are you gonna do it yes sir good
how old are you Tom
I'm 32. and you're a good man this kid
hey this kid this kid's lucky to have
used that and here's what Dave and I are
also giving you in about 10 years he's
he'll be 11 he'll make you a real mad
and in a fit of rage you can turn and
stare him in directly in the eyes and
say I stole the car for you I gave up a
Civic for you
and then he'll be like seriously and
you'll be like yeah yeah that didn't go
then it goes as hard as I thought I was
going to not much of a flagship
I thought that was going to go way
harder than it did man
[Music]
I'll let the school counselor know next
time we meet
see
sell the Civic brother
oh Tom you're a good guy I appreciate
your question Tom you're awesome brother
yeah here's the thing folks um
very seldom are we as boxed in and
trapped as sometimes we feel like we are
uh because sometimes there's a simple
thing you can throw a stick of dynamite
right in the middle of it blow it up and
you go oh well look at there
and yeah there it is
[Laughter]
oh that's so great but I do think it's
important if if there's a you're in the
household together and you're not making
eye contact every day but there is
passing there is they see you every day
then I'm gonna tell you to go run and
get this thing done because the
long-term stress in your household is
not gonna be worth it that stress exists
but in that case I would sell the car
too a hundred percent yeah if I'm
worried about I would drive there if I'm
worried about being there for my
one-year-old a hundred percent I'm not
trading a car for that there's not a
circumstance no not at all no not at all